краї треба порушити базові романські
права в принципі не травня проводять і
великі міжнародні турніри процесу
його член бундестагу Міхаель fox
за тут на голови фракції правда тяга
блоку хдс і хсс у парламенті немечений
поважаючи доступному руку багатого були
валянки і так відривається вид дорогою в
росію через ситуацію там праворуч
любимо і вінтер ікони ще б після того
кращого ти на жаль тортури крайні потребу
хоча росія в дружини ширша за коло ці він
і безтурботно муна прям у про по вершині
розуму ви знову не і громадянського
істоти
заявив губернатор лор впав на важливий
наймати кого уряду випробувано спершу
бітність вас росію
ви можете ернесто чемпіонат свято 2018
уроку менше україну
звучати на бенкет ширик за крима пися
корупційного скандалу а фіфа алла чіпі
дохід разів захисних краї на бойкот
футбольна поді і такого масштабу додому
до експерта vc мало йому вірна і рішення
про вітання Росії право на
проведення чемпіонату можемо холод етики
фіфа а у неї іжевську фінансові інтереси
і ці постраждають у росі принесення купа
їжі і бойкот і хороша оббивка зате
росії на її допоміг і db котова то
чемпіонат квіти футболу в Росії Петро і
мули дав ікони всім континент чини
досвіду ні до чого або злетиш так з
вожатий на людей і там живуть і кулі
tokyo та нормальні люди та ківі чують на
знижки на борту забувати і про випадкові
людей
ніки хоче від рима ти задавав не вигляд
футболу на дрова рубає і політичним
інструментом я прямую йди бойкоту
будь-яку мережу і він залишиться в силу роки
вже підписання і ми вірні нічого не
зміниться та на ці чемпіонати проводиться
у краї на вікіни зовсім 6s. зірка
демократії сова за
піч пропонуючи проти і кіт у нього роти
змішувати політику і спорт від ще
думаєш я думаю спорт young вулиця часті
на політиці
я все там ви до ростова зручний хаба і
дайте про корупцію і провалю дін і сем
Жінка спорту так він експерт а також
означають у рази хлопець з і не чемпіонату
за русі і жадібно скро инна в сором 5
zarik